a cup of coffee a piece of bread Rama
map embolus says you need nothing more
than that to make you feel human an
equal among equals Rama is actually
homeless on the edge of society with no
documents and no prospects so sometimes
the simple breakfast can mean the world
it's an enormous pleasure an enormous
satisfaction to be able to benefit from
Monsieur been solidarity everyone calls
him miss you Ben or just plain been in
fact his name is Ahmed Ben abdirahman
and he comes from Morocco he opened his
hotel in Brussels 19 years ago and
called it Mozart his oriental dream come
true a three star hotel as colorful as
Monsieur Ben's own story tobacco play
hotels aren't always full especially in
winter in January in February when it's
very cold I let people in you see I put
myself in their place and when they look
at me with gratitude in their eyes it's
a joy boo muah salut salut joie so then
opens his doors to people in need
everyone gets breakfast here and off in
a room whether they can pay or not and
so far none of the paying guests have
complained on the contrary
it's more people in the world will like
this man not a poignant you have to be
happy about it there's so much misery in
the world Oh j.mull time you say n0 it's
always the same story without a
residence permit there's no permission
to work without work there's no
residence permit Roma actually had
worked for years for a painting and
decorating firm but at some point there
was no longer enough to do his boss had
to let him go that meant his work permit
was gone after six months he could no
longer pay his rent and ended up on the
street Ramon doesn't talk much about
life on the street and when he does he
avoid speaking about himself he only
talks about other homeless people and
life on the street in general here
behind a church in central Brussels he
had a place to sleep for four months it
was a dangerous life wake honest with
you see when there are seven or eight
drunks together anything can happen they
go berserk they become violent they mock
everything and everybody they don't care
at all for the lives of the people who
sleep here the sleeping quarters are
immaculately clean and tidy ramal says
the people who sleep here aren't drunks
no drugs no alcohol just bad luck in
life
oh ma shows us the people lying on the
other side of the church those whose
lives have been destroyed by alcohol
things look different there seven months
ago ramaa met been since then he's lived
in the hotel with a roof over his head a
proper bed and a clean shower Ramon will
never forget the moment he arrived Wow
sanook assume it's better than in my own
home a bathroom and a television when I
came in here and saw the picture of a
soldier I thought voila that's what I
have to do keep fighting so he sets out
armed with his documents he wants to
talk with no less than the president of
Belgium's Upper House the Senate and the
police officer at the entrance doesn't
send him away but instead politely
explains how to get to the visitors
entrance perhaps is the presence of our
camera but after a while someone
actually arrives to hear about Romans
plight and promises to do something
about it a huge surprise I believe a lot
because you still don't feel right now
I'm very satisfied I've met the Senate
President spokesman that's a step
forward Oh contenido wooden and then
Roma once again has to do what so many
in hotel mozart have to do wait for an
answer from the Senate and hope that
something in his life will finally
improve waiting he tells us is the
hardest thing
you